so I left my house when I was 12. I
started my own business at 23. wow very
successful at the salons hair massage
everything good for you my son he
started his own business okay we're by
Big Heads because he comes to meet her
advice and I just know my way
I tried you tell him right you know but
he doesn't doesn't want to listen yeah
everything about the business season
either so of course it's kind of bad
right but it's too bad I've watched your
videos and you're like you're like no
you know everyone doesn't know
everything that's right but I think I
know everything I'm a Latina so you know
how that goes fair enough right so
what's the problem should I stop or just
encourage should you stop telling him
your thoughts no you shouldn't tell them
what to do you should tell them how you
would do it and then let him decide how
he will do it based on how you would do
it sometimes that's the only good thing
that's the part that [__] Mom's up you
don't want him to fall in his ass the
best thing that can happen to him is he
falls on his ass even if he goes into
of course
of course it's hard it's not your
principle but you but if you let him go
in debt
first of all if you're telling him
everything that he's doing wrong and he
starts going into debt slowly he's going
to know that you are right
and he's not going to go as deep into
debt as you think
look you can't over you he can't have it
both ways
he can't
just have to sit back and watch yes
he inhabit both ways
right he can't be [__] on Mom and
that's wrong but also asking for like
going into like he's gotta he's got to
live
on his own you definitely did if you
left the 12 and did your thing you made
a [__] ton of mistakes
of course I know what you mean which is
why I'm telling you it's the flip of
what you think every second you're over
protecting him is more of him becoming a
losing fighter
debt is good for him
he has no other option what are you
going to over coddle him to the grave no
so he's going to end up being insecure
because he's gonna think his mom never
believed in him and more importantly
he's gonna end up being insecure because
he is seeing through your actions that
you're over coddling him thus meaning
you don't think he can do it
he's better off losing than having a mom
that doesn't think he can do it
yeah yeah losing is good you're right
you got it yeah yeah yeah yes I'm like
six months in around this business
you're not all motivated do you love it
yeah I love it well then that's good
yeah even the way you just reacted like
just talking to your mom having that
context like what are you scared of
failing not like actually what other
people think almost of course it's also
like lonely of course it's extremely
lonely it's real lonely out here for
entrepreneurs
couple things one you'll always lose in
life if you overvalue them it it's a
wrap you're gonna have to start
practicing getting like you have to
fight for that you have to like you have
to fight you have to like really
meditation reading positive things in
your ears whatever the [__] it is
exercise I don't know what it is you
gotta practice having them judge you
have to
have to then it starts getting Less
Lonely Too once you get over that first
hump
what ends up happening is when you're
not scared you become more vulnerable
and open and more [__] starts coming to
you when you're scared you're blocking
people you're blocking energy
you're like well yeah you don't want to
talk to anybody you're scared if they're
gonna be like you're a dork
of course you're like I got a t-shirt
exactly but I respect that more you're
doing thank you you're doing foreign
like I I [__] stock shelves in a
store for [__] 20 years of my life
before I did anything
wow is right
thank you so much you're welcome brother
thank you have a great day you
understand why don't you get over that
part it all comes